A mysterious flying object flew in the wind of Japan to the Kyosho boss and flew away from the ground and buildings one after another. According to
international communication, flying objects are flying not only in Japan but also in countries around the world.  It's
been reported
that someday April Fool's Day is flying with this kid, so it's been a long time since it's been a long time
.  In that case, is
n't Oomataka's budget huge?
We
're supposed to be Sawai, too, and since then it's been an encounter with the unknown
, is
n't it?
It's like a mysterious baptism that flew into the sky, and
the structures on the ground have been
erased.
The International Defense Headquarters has
announced that it will guarantee the parts that will save the mysterious life form from being scooped up in English.
no